Oh devote to ferry where's my son has he
gone missing he's not missing it was
taken I'm here for a reason why the
lesson for today there are no happy
endings this body may be you this
Tuesday at 8/7 central on the CW hey
everybody it's the mid-season finale on
the flash let's break this down there's
also a bunch of images too because in
that footage they didn't have any of the
Amunet black caitlin stuff that's going
on and that's like the other part of
this storyline so for all the thinker
stuff that's going on which we'll talk
about in a second which is also a bit of
a throwback to earth one reverse flash
from some moments earlier this season in
the crossover there's also this whole
other caitlin thing going on you see a
little bit of it when there's a big
explosion in jitters so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's
gonna be flash stuff DC TV and DC movie
stuff happening all throughout the break
but just like normal there is new
giveaway stuff at the end of this too so
like I said Barry gets kidnapped by the
thinker Caitlin gets kidnapped by Amunet
black and is forced to help her so if
you're wondering why the thinker has
kidnapped Barry because he asked them
straight up in that trailer why do you
want me obviously I'm here for a reason
and if it wasn't clear the room that
they're in is speedster proof whatever
the thinker did to it like you see Barry
use his Speed Force and try to grab him
right out of the chair but the thinker
is able to grab him whatever technology
he's built into that place I think he's
taken away all the physical advantages
that Barry would have being a speedster
so it's literally turning into a battle
of wits that's the only way for Barry to
help him but the title of the episode is
don't run as in a monster's chasing
after you somebody kidnaps you normally
your instinct would be to run away but
they're like you know don't run away so
Caitlin is forced to help Amunet black
it sounds like the flash is going to be
forced to help the thinker because he's
slowly dying so in both scenarios both
of the heroes are forced to help
villains do something that will
ultimately be kind of good you can kind
of see the way they're twisting the
villain are
this season likes avatar was
unequivocally bad he was going to kill
iris they had to stop him some weight
like nothing he was doing was good
there was going to be no benefit to
anybody on team flash unless you worse
avatar then you would become savage AR
because he was trying to turn it into a
self-fulfilling prophecy kill iris so
that Barry would turn into Savitt AR
this season it's all about defeating the
villain but the thing is like when you
saw that thinker flashback he's not that
bad he actually wants to help the world
but he has this degenerative condition
so the thing that's helping him save the
world his mind is literally eating his
body so it's starting to twist him up
and he needs the flash to help him
complete his task but the reason why
he's a villain is because of the ways
that he's trying to get the flash to
help him out like he's manipulating him
getting to create more speedsters trying
to move him around like a chess piece
rather than go to him as a friend would
like during the crossover but here's the
really cool thing so I talked about
earth-1 reverse flash remember in the
thinker flashback we went back to the
season 1 pilot where the particle
accelerator went off and they had that
scene with the crowd where earth won
eobard Wells was addressing everyone
explaining that there wouldn't be any
problems the thinker's wife objects then
he narrows in on the thinker who hasn't
become the thinker yet and says you must
be Clifford DeVoe I'm a big fan
so the reverse-flash that Barry fought
during the crossover is the same reverse
flash that created the thinker with that
Dark Matter explosion in the first
season that's probably one of the big
reasons why they wanted to use that
version of the reverse flash during the
crossover rather than just have him be
the earth X version of Harrison wells so
I know there's still a lot of questions
about why in particular they said that
he's not dead because we saw him get
vaporized at the end of season 1 because
Eddie killed himself so he should have
never existed in time travel was really
tricky they have funny ways of joking
about that time travel it's a tricky
thing I will do a video this weekend
just explaining what's going on with the
reverse flashes what his timeline is and
how it's possible that he's still alive
but there's a couple more videos from
the crossover it'll take a little while
to get to because of all the infinity
war stuff that happened this week like
we have to talk about tornado twins Bart
Allen and the other speedsters that come
for Barry dyrus so if you're wondering
why they're focusing on that
season it also circles back around to
thinker stuff like the thinkers legacy
he wants to fix the world he wants to be
this great man but he can't do that if
he dies before he achieves his goal so
the funny thing about this is that all
Barry has to do to defeat the thinker is
literally just wait him out his life is
on a ticking clock based on the amount
of time he said he had when he was
talking to that doctor in the flashback
that puts it right around the season
finale of season four
so like Barry could just sit around do
nothing in the thinker would expire on
his own but I think part of the fun this
season is in learning what the thinkers
trying to do learning that it's not
quite so bad and then seeing how Barry
actually tries to help him a little bit
and then that goes sideways and they
wind up fighting each other anyway
that's the whole thing they did it
during season three with saboteur
because for a brief second they did make
you wonder if they were going to try and
redeem saboteur but then it all turned
out to be a trick of his like he was
just trying to manipulate them so that
might wind up being the same thing that
happens with the thinker but then
somewhere along the way in the back half
of the season he just goes completely
off the rails
maybe he kills one of the other members
of team flash like he's threatening Joe
in the trailer but of all the people
that are on my death predictions list
Cecille is a little bit higher just
because they keep hyping her up but I
don't think that they would kill her
before she had her baby but it's a
little too early to predict who they're
gonna kill at the end of the season but
just let me know based on the evidence
so far who do you think that they killed
this season because there's got to be at
least one more big heartbreaking death
in the back half there's this really
small moment in the trailer - I love
that Cisco tries to vibe where Barry is
in some defense that the thinker has
causes it to reflect back on Cisco and
it's almost like a Freddy Krueger dream
warrior situation like the thinker
attacks Cisco in his own vibe and he
flies into that blue Christmas tree but
I know a lot of you are also asking
where was the thinker during the
crossover and why did he just let
everything go down so I think that's
because he said during the last episode
of the flash before the crossover that
he was going to let Barry get married
and because he sort of charts all the
different possibilities different
timelines that could go down he probably
had a pretty strong idea that that would
eventually happen that the heroes would
be victorious and then he could go get
Barry to do what he wanted
do but I'm really curious to see how
close to the Geoff Johns thinker arc
this is because the whole reason why the
thinker wanted the Flash's mind in the
comics is is because he had this
limitless processing ability because of
his connection to the dark matter speed
force enhanced brain plus the thinker
equals the super version of the thinker
so he might wind up trying to take part
of Barry's mind but just remember this
comic book panel with all the wires
sticking to his brain we saw that happen
to the thinker during episode 7 we might
get to see a version of this in the
mid-season finale and if not then then
eventually later this season and the
other really big thing that just
happened it's kind of bad kind of good
they actually fired the showrunner from
the flash and Supergirl he was kind of
running both shows and usually when you
lose a showrunner from a really strong
show or two he winds up being a bad
thing because they replaced them with
somebody who's worse but Greg Berlanti
himself is actually now running both of
the flash and the Supergirl writers
rooms and whatever you thought of the
season so far he's actually just every
bit the comic book nerd that Geoff Johns
is he's a huge flash comic book nerd he
was the one that originally wanted to do
the flash TV show and then brought
everybody else in on it but for however
long maybe for the rest of the season he
will be personally overseeing the rest
of the story on the flash and Supergirl
so even if you only watched the flash
they kind of got a big upgrade in terms
of their writers room now that he's
giving his full attention to the flash
and Supergirl - so kind of a bad
situation but something good came out of
it so there is a new round of that blast
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is just be a subscriber leave a
flash related comments on the video
congratulations to the winner from the
last video door B magic please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here to rewatch the
infinity war trailer a billion more
times and click here for my crossover
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight